laid back lay back and flatten out
meatballs
why are you trying to wrestle me dog
hold on i can't lift you
so what are you doing
like keep your hips up because you're
sticking your ass out and it's like
pushing down does that make sense no it
doesn't no
stand up straight okay i'm trying to
bend so i can no no don't bend don't
bend it off keep your body you almost
have to do a trust fall yeah you have to
do a truss ball okay right another truss
ball hold it hold it tight
hold it tight
oh yeah
[Music]
i came in there was a big laugh what was
the joke i missed it
did we oh well
it isn't it isn't because part of this i
think we can keep and part of it we
can't
we're like
we were talking about i was telling uh
christian about how like when i first
started working for fire and kid
something had happened and i was like
suicidal for that entire year and he's
like oh who hasn't been suicidal and
then chappelle said oh i ha i wasn't he
also was going to make a joke about
calling christian ugly but like it was
like a serious moment i was like oh you
were suicidal he goes yeah i was like oh
because you're ugh yeah like he was
leaving as christian was like being
heartfelt yeah yeah so it was like ooh
and then we all laughed christian paused
versus yeah you felt it he felt like hey
chappelle had a blast you can't treat
him with kid gloves that's a great burn
but what was going on meat um it was
just it was well it was the fact that i
was paying like making minimum wage
working at two different restaurants and
the fact that i had to pay seven hundred
dollars to
not even have my own couch i had to
share a couch with someone and sleep on
a pull out couch with someone else on
that couch did you know the person yeah
we have no one from it's we talked about
in the last episode it's the guy who you
know
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then all all my
money was he was going into rent
so and i my parents would have helped me
out if i reached out to them i just was
too proud to so like there were weeks
like where i would like me and the kid
would literally
look through the couch for change just
to get enough money to go to smart and
final and get bread and cheese and live
off of grilled cheeses for a week so how
good was that how good was that first
grilled cheese when you got enough
chicken
i've been there think about it i
remember one dude when i first moved out
here and i had i had dog [ __ ] for money
i was working at a daycare that i didn't
pay much and man i was just like i just
want a bean and cheese burrito from taco
bell and when i had that [ __ ]
oh it just hit no but i get what you're
saying like i don't know if i ever like
had the feeling of like suicidal as much
as i was just like
i didn't want to like exist
around people like that i feel like
that's uh
that falls under suicidal because i
don't think it's always necessarily you
want to kill yourself i don't want to be
here no it wasn't even like i just
didn't want to be around
people oh okay so if you got yourself
when i was in my dark area like
i i was just like man i just want to
move away
to some like
area where no one would really know work
a regular yeah job which would probably
would have been like a minimum wage job
because all i have is a high school
diploma mm-hmm so they don't think i do
but anyways but but that's all i wanted
to like do luckily now just after dark
yeah
this is after time
welcome back to cats after dark okay
nick with that [ __ ] sly move there i
see that i haven't uh
i've never
i have this stand-up bit that i've never
done in stand-up because i haven't done
that i haven't done like open mics for
years uh but
i never really did huh i forgot you did
yeah yeah when i was living in my car
uh but
probably when i wrote wrote this bit but
i was like i've never i've never planned
on killing myself but i've thought about
killing myself a lot you like you go
through you go through like the the
machinations like man everybody be so
sad right
and then i come to the conclusion i just
don't have it in me i got yeah i got too
much to do you remember what i've never
i've never want like wanted to kill
myself that's kind of the bit like a
delineation of just thinking about i
think everyone's done that yeah but did
you ever have you guys ever thought like
if you were gonna do it this is what i
would think of doing no yep yeah i have
to
what are we doing yeah mine okay my
thing is i just don't want my my family
or friends to ever find out just i want
to go missing but i'm like how do i go
missing yes but that's worse so because
no i can't you know how to go out
the time i think if they found out i
killed myself it would just destroy them
so make it sound like you make it seem
like you were get uh you got murdered
then how about that
and plus i don't want to suffer so the
only thing i can think of is like
finding this crazy cliff like with beach
and just hauling my car flying out there
and just flying and going i didn't want
to ever do it it was just
when my darkest days that was like in my
head dude we've all had them dark days i
had that same thing you wanted to do
move away work at a best buy there's
nothing against work at best buy but i
was like work best buy first of my life
get one one a studio apartment and just
live and just no one knows
yeah where no one knew you you didn't
have to talk to anybody that's how i
felt i never
i never thought about like self-harm
isolation was what you wanted was just
like isolation you know just removing
myself from like people it was i mean it
was because i you know lost my brother
and my best friend
and so
i just didn't want to get close with
people ever again because i was like
those were the two most significant
people in my life so i was like why
would i
why do i want to get close to people and
again and then here i am with you guys
close to everyone after dark wow after
dark this is a support group do you do
you feel like a completely changed
person who's like closer to people or do
you force yourself to be affable so then
like you get in that mindset
you use the word affable yeah
i mean like happy yeah you're warm
[Laughter]
someone said in uh youtube comments of
what are the shows i read them all for a
new segment where you're going to do
called errors and omissions where we
correct things we've gotten wrong so oh
that'd be great so far it's only been me
pretty much
i talk on my butt i guess but someone
was like uh
chappelle should play are you smarter
than a fifth
grader why on the show oh i would get my
ass
i feel like most adults on that tv show
used to get their ass kicked but the
only thing i know is music
if you if you you're trying to give me
you try to give me with anything else
i'm like
i feel like you'd be pretty somewhat
history i i did love history history was
my favorite subject geography you might
be good at your last geography
yeah well give me a question throw
something at me find something on the
internet meatball let's see geography
what is the capital of nevada
uh
is it reno no
it's not i know
give him one more try i feel like it's
on the tip of his tongue i think i know
oh my god
i'm gonna beat myself up one once you
tell me this answer do you know what
nick i think okay throw it out there
what do you think wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
oh man yes of where [ __ ] what is that
nevada carson's carson city i would
never guess yeah i thought vegas i'm
gonna keep the camera on me the whole
time so they know i don't look at my
they didn't look at my phone yeah yeah
yeah we can vouch you did not look this
way phones away look at our throw throw
one of them first great questions
before we take these quizzes though you
know what we have to do what gets in
focus
oh yeah uh yeah you can't be asking me
questions if i haven't taken magic mine
don't throw that [ __ ] over here though
remember we get to get mine we get to
take magic mine let's throw it out there
back to your affable question mm-hmm um
oh yeah i no i think once i became at
peace with myself as an individual i was
honest about a lot of things in my life
that i was never honest with before i
think that made me okay
with uh being around people there's this
thing that there's this quote that i
like it's kind of like stuck with me
that i thought was like really dope
um
it stuck with me more so recently but it
it it has so many layers to it but can i
read it yeah i'll do it a question yeah
i love it
so
thank you i followed so many damn
stoicism pages but but the the uh the
quote is you don't trust that someone's
never gonna betray you you just trust
that you'll be able to handle it if they
do yeah which i think is like
there's a lot of layers to that since i
think it's beyond like
being betrayed or anything like that but
like even
you know
yeah like we're losing a loved one in my
life i had to learn how to be able to
handle that you know what i mean so like
that i think once i was able to figure
out all that stuff
you know a lot of things
once you figure out what matters
and what you do have
then it's like easier it's easier to
walk through life for sure that's what
it was do you have the book the daily
stoic
uh no i don't have that book it's it's
uh it got really popular ryan holidays i
love ryan yeah he's he's one of the guys
who's like really responsible for
bringing like uh stoicism to the
forefront of like yeah a lot a lot of
people it's more in pop culture now a
lot of people a lot of people um and it
has like very similar tenets to uh
in summer sex buddhism some re respects
christianity uh aaa tenants are like
very stoic uh it's like uh effects
uh change the things you can
i can't remember whatever that that
prayer uh yeah addicts they have not won
yeah but a lot of the same tenants and
ryan holiday he's wrote a couple books
on stoicism and one that he wrote was
the daily stoic and it's just like
every day like it's a bedstand book or
every day you read one page yeah it's
got like a
like a tenant from some stoic
philosophers like writings like marcus
marcus
and then he breaks it down like what how
that can be the practical application in
today's society that's good it's a
one-day reminder yeah
i didn't learn about stoicism until i
moved to
la and then once i found it i was like
oh this is like
and i think that's why i haven't really
you know
like i don't know i i've even when
things come at me like oh say i don't
get a gig or whatever like it doesn't
really like affect me i can't even tell
you what gigs i haven't gotten because a
lot of times it doesn't really affect me
in a way to where it's like oh [ __ ] you
know like i didn't get that gig that i
wanted or whatever just because it's
like
you know whatever there's
i don't know just kind of found this way
of like there's there's more to come you
know there's more things that happen and
it's all it's all about just like habits
and like not focusing on results like if
you know you're doing the right things
just keep doing every day [ __ ] will work
out maybe not exactly as you planned but
yeah don't let them hear that meatball
yeah yeah it's like when you try to do
that bench press and you can't get it
what bench press do you ever hit the
bench press on you i'm saying yeah i hit
the bench press i've never seen you you
never see me bruh let me go to my
instagram and you could see all the
bench pressing
i do not think i ever we were just
talking about you being stoic and now
you're riled up i don't know
i just never see you work out when
you're when we're at this gym this guy
mark and brendan i'm not kidding i'll be
in the middle of my workout
and then i'll
an hour later i'm still working out they
come in they're just talking for about
45 years an hour i
the biggest guys are always just
standing around talking how do they
because they're power lifters power
lifters need five minutes between every
set you wanna you wanna
here's why you're lying
when they were talking i said meatball
will you help me with this ball and
catch it while i do some uh sit-ups i
was like
no no
this is like last week could you bench
him right now easy [ __ ] can we do it
how would we i don't know how would we
do that how do we do it on camera i feel
like you would have to lay down and then
like press him yeah that's what i'm like
you so you see what i said you guys
first of all you guys are trying to give
me the ass to ask me [ __ ] elementary
school questions and you're trying to
give me the adventurous magic mind
magically i need my [ __ ] cheers
before i do that
we can't hear you or see you
i know right
where's my camera
and we're gonna need to fire off the
song after we take it too yeah just come
back over just come back over yeah
i love the way you found your camera and
sat on the arm of the camera first of
all i was trying to say get away from me
i know
[Laughter]
bro let's get this magic line out yeah i
love this [ __ ] stuff i know everyone
does
i mean
oh and that we he's got the video too
that's what i'm pulling up
are you ready quick yeah i like that
what the [ __ ]
cheers
[Music]
wake up and go and get it clarity when i
think first time i ever really felt
productive when
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
ask me a first quick question right now
because no no no we're going to have you
not only are we going to ask her a first
quarter question but we're going to ask
you it while you try and bench me
bro you wave i benched 315 pounds so
let's see if why the [ __ ] would i [ __ ]
and it won't be
let's just see if he can bench you i
think this is funny because this is not
the first time
christian has asked someone to lift him
because he was trying to dispute me one
of the first like few months he was
working here he's like oh you used to
lift you but like you couldn't lift me
as if he was heavy
like you're a buck like 35 at most in my
life
probably then but now i'm 150 yeah
[Laughter]
this is fun this is fun turn around so
in wrestling they do the gorilla press
and they grab their crotch
oh that's a gorilla
uh
yeah
see you got to grab his crotch
he's got him
no don't you're like uh you got to keep
your body short you got to squeeze your
core yeah
i got to squeeze my core yeah well
squeeze your forehead
you got to get in there like a
quarterback and grab his ass dude yeah
you did this all your exercises
why are you trying to wrestle me dog
hold on i can't lift you
so what are you doing
like keep your hips up because you're
sticking your ass out and it's like push
him down
does that make sense no it doesn't no
stand up straight okay i'm trying to
bend so i can go no no don't bend don't
bend at all keep your body straight you
almost have to do a trust fall yeah you
have to do a truss ball okay right i
know first
[Laughter]
wisconsin
oh my god love it
well that went exactly how i wanted it
amazing
and i don't even feel tired because i'm
on magic mine yeah
crazy right all right crazy well good
because now either
i say we only ask a couple and now we
ask our fans if there is is anybody who
has a child who watches this show
fourth or fifth grade and we have oh my
god battling your children yes
uh so just like ask one kind of warm up
for next week i'll ask one from each
grade it's first to fifth okay five
questions okay all right are they we're
on we're just
the floor is about the flora chapelle
let's do flora chappelle and then he
gets like one help hotline from each of
us if he needs it if you want if i need
it yeah we may not know the answers
either
promo code
please buy more of it oh also another
thing i want to say
if you
email cats after dark gmail.com a
receipt of your magic mind thing we'll
zoom you in and you can give your
testimonial and we'll learn about that
nice what do you want to do math history
first grade history
math history english language arts or
uh science let's do first grade history
i knew it yeah of course you got this
all right
ready i'm gonna look
to see which one i want to give you
all right
now don't disrespect me [ __ ]
this is a first grade question all right
the statue of liberty was a gift from
where
uh france
what in the
good job chapel solid i love how
surprised chinese by the way
oh my gosh i know it sounded like not
[ __ ] too big
did you know the answer no that's why
yeah that's right really
i would be like didn't you have to know
that to get citizenship
but i'm not good
yeah i know that
okay you can stay
thanks nick
great app so yeah great oh my god we
recorded yeah
recording thank god we are fifth check
six check
all right uh
now do we go to second grade or second
grade yeah let's go second grade what
are the three branches of the united
states government
no i didn't say no i i thought you
oh he wants categories uh different
categories oh different categories yeah
all right this is like jeopardy
[ __ ] all right so what do you
want what do you got english math or
science is left
english
all right so we'll do an english second
grade uh second grade
i'm just like
none of these are yeah i don't
understand like what kind of question
would you ask for english exactly yeah
what are the five interrogative or
question words
interrogative yeah oh interrogative
entertainment but yeah interrogative you
wanna bet
i know you're a gambler
[Laughter]
interrogative i think it is
yeah it's interrogative interrogating is
different but it's similar nick you are
like i will give you the uh credit
question
in a way
who what when where
why yes
oh damn chef i was like i know this [ __ ]
dude you're blowing chin's mine right
now i mean it's [ __ ] elementary i
didn't check to see if chappelle's
checking his phone though no i don't
have one i'm kidding i
wow
wow i got a lot of self-reflecting
videos
i'm sorry
english is english is my like i love
that they get the date just get the
daily stuff i was great at it in high
school
all right throw uh what are we on third
grade now third grade uh science and
math is left
really
oh maybe we'll stump you now third grade
we'll do science third grade science all
right
they're bold you're leaving like the
hardest math question for the end it's a
good progression now you're gonna have
to do a fourth or fifth
yeah yeah wait there's only four
categories yeah but there's five well
there's geography too but oh okay
no well grammar spelling and that's it
okay um i did one show
you what a [ __ ] spelling third
grade science science yep
i'm pregnant i'm actually pretty [ __ ]
smart i mean it's elementary school
actually you are smart so remember to
give yourself
compliment yeah dude these are [ __ ]
stop doing all right you're smart um
which planet is closest to the sun
i don't actually don't know but um
ain't a multiple choice
i mean you can phone in help if you'd
like from one of us
cat
immediately
um my guess is mars only because the god
of war is always associated with mars
but i don't know how accurate that is i
was like i don't think no sorry oh
you're supposed to say final answer
that's not what
cause that's because it's always like i
give the answer and then he confirms
whether he's going to go with that or
change it yeah then
the millionaire game whatever what's
called who wants to be a millionaire
that's that's the rules of that yeah
that's what i'm saying yeah so give me a
break you are the weakest link goodbye
um honestly though that third grade uh
history question one of them was what
are the branches of government why is it
why is the second grader supposed to
know that
they teach them
they do teach you any of you guys know i
don't remember uh judicial
legislative and uh
what is the
whoever the president is executive
executive yeah wow see i did not know
that neither did i um all right so
that's definitely a question on the
citizenship test would be another fun
thing first of all
like
we could do all kinds of tasks
wait what the what says
i do not want to be near chin or cat
when they do a driving test a driving
test why are you trying to say that uh
i'm
i wouldn't say i'm the best driver but
i'm pretty good at parking on myself
you're not i was just kidding you're not
a bad driver he tried he tried the whole
racist thing you're so pure of heart you
didn't even get it yeah it was pretty it
was pretty obvious oh what happened the
joke the racist joke but you're you're
like what do you mean i know yeah
what do you mean what is that who's the
one that had an accident not too long
ago
hey exactly
you know what
let's play get guess the ethnicity of
the person who crashed into me or that
you crashed into i no they hit the side
of my car
so
what happens what's the end of this no
facebook
what's the verdict on that thing as far
as insurance and everything else it's
her fault so she has to pay i just
[ __ ] i didn't hear back from her
insurance company so i got to the point
where i needed my car so i just paid it
out of pocket
that's your fault in that means you were
at fault actually no 50 50.
okay that's that's fair technically oh
maybe then you can't put it all on her i
know i know i mean he told me the story
before she was first off she was
speeding
i was already in the lane she had plenty
of time to see me she almost hit where
my door was so my car was click my
bright blue car
was in the lane so the fact that she
couldn't see that
i mean how is that my fault
wow
i'm just getting out racist give me the
give me the fourth grade no we're going
oh fifth grade since it's the last
question i don't think we ever got the
answer to the we didn't work oh mercury
what was it what was it i didn't hear
the question what's the planet closely
closest to the sun and you said mercury
right no i said mom she was close
and i actually was gonna say
real quick you know that saying mercury
is in retrospect yeah that's a huge
saying too right especially for
spiritual people yeah it's like people
were into astrology too right astrology
is like oh yeah that's really like
popped off in the last couple years it's
just very trendy yeah it's very it's so
trendy but also it's like
i mean i don't want to base my life off
of like how i walked through life off
that it's the opposite of stoicism yeah
total opportunity i'm like i'm not going
to base it off [ __ ] stars
you know
all right what's the fourth grade one
fifth grade fifth grade we're going
hardest since the last question all
right
um
and it's math
yeah i'm trying to see which one
i'd like
i mean these are all pretty [ __ ] easy
um i did terribly in school i'm sorry
that's why i said fifth grade math you
got the m right if a football field is
100 yards long how many feet long is the
football field
a hundred what if a football field is a
hundred yards long would you like to do
the math no we haven't what do you mean
what do you mean nope
well he's still doing the math he would
just have to like physically write down
i don't think that takes away his
ability writing this down would help
would it
yeah
i know about a football field
yeah if a football cause you would
convert it it's math yeah how would you
even convert that because
you go for short
this is very telling go on okay a
hundred yards oh uh is it uh how many
feet are in a hundred yards
wait
wait say it again if a football field
how many feet is a football field yeah
how many feet is a football goal like
it's going 100 yards how many footer in
a yard 12.
no but damn it that's awesome
[Music]
[Laughter]
behind the one two two gosh i don't know
i don't know how many videos in your
yard cold
[Music]
[Music]
two feet
hotter
three
hot
it's three feet in the yard three feet
in a yard
then what's that twill
i think you're thinking inches in a foot
that's what it was okay so yeah that's
what it was with the information we've
gathered
with him holding in a friend from
everybody yeah 3 000. yes we got it
300. all right i was wrong 300.
chin you said 3 000 i don't agree with
you you got it this is sparta 300.
what's the three yeah three times a
hundred three hundred times jesus i
thought you would know better man the
whiskey bro wow
why would you think you know you don't
know you're catching on
uh uh
tricky question is yeah how many yards
is a football field goal posted goal
post a hundred yards 120. whoa yeah at
the end
20 yards yeah
220. look at that gambler
who holds the all right another tricky
question who holds the record for most
touchdowns ever did i die and go to
heaven trivia questions
uh most touchdowns ever is brady are we
talking passing
uh receiver uh jerry right uh jerry rice
really yeah by a mile by a mile he has
all receiving records by like yeah what
about running back
most running back touchdowns wait
yeah
holy damn i was going to say i was going
to say lt actually with anytime lt for
running back but uh we saw the answer on
the screen oh my bad then lt used to
have the long earring
was that that guy oh that was a
different lt so this is lt
the running back who played for the
chargers in the 2000s they they actually
some people called him ldt because they
didn't like him being confused with
lawrence taylor
that was the guy that had the area yeah
he was the linebacker from the giants in
like the 80s and it was all coked up and
lots of sexual allegations against
lawrence taylor oh right now no just uh
throughout the years he had like a 14
year old girl in his hotel room one time
fact-check me fact-check me this is a
great segue into arizona missions our
new segment
uh lawrence taylor yeah yeah fact check
him for sexual assault uh do lawrence
taylor wiki and then go to his personal
life
and they'll probably that's how
that's how you find that [ __ ]
are you on there meatball
oh wait what the [ __ ]
i was wondering why you guys couldn't
see it
come on meatball
what does it say maybe i made it up
under this is why we factor right here
we are not
wrap up uh the wrap-up sixteen-year-old
girls
very yeah that's still very very bad
very bad
weirdly legal in some states so i feel
like it is important distinction from 14
but nonetheless uh he sounds like i used
to feel so weird about that because
growing up i used to watch gossip girl
and they were the characters were older
than i was when i was watching the show
so i didn't quite understand what like
consent was because i knew in california
it was 18 but in new york it was 16. so
they had storylines where these high
school kids were hooking up with their
teachers and professors saying oh but
it's illegal and it's okay because i'm
16 so i can consent so i was like huh
wait gossip girls with leighton meester
yes damn i'm good good i was sitting on
that i was like is that really late
meester do you like late meester i
actually do yeah did you like her music
when she uh started doing it yeah with
cobra starship
so i just met that guy i don't know oh
the guy from
now yeah
is he still making music i was just
listening to good girls gone bad like
yesterday yeah yeah that's why yeah yeah
he manages and stuff like that dope dude
the first like lively's up in there too
yeah blake lightweight
girl
hey gorgeous yo shout out to you for
showing me your girl gorgeous
she is cute she has a girl that looks
just like her another actress they did a
movie together yeah and they're sisters
i forgot oh she was rudy
no that's a different
show
what's uh rudy's like gilmore girls
some someone else yeah wait was she in
the oc uh no that's someone else too
that's rachel bilson i believe are we
off hey yo
yo she showed me an actress
anna de armas
she was in blade runner the most recent
one she
was in james bond recently she's going
to be playing marilyn monroe soon in the
biopic she did it i just heard the name
no no none of the things oh she's going
to see this bruh christian go to anna
the diversion what is it
uh anna de armas she is a ecuadorian
woman she got casted in the movie war
dogs and she didn't speak any english at
that point she actually learned her
lines by memorizing the english sounds
that the words sounded like and so she
did the entire film not knowing what she
was really saying incredible oh this
girl your girlfriend
what was her gorgeous her first language
uh spanish
might have a woman sorry i gave you the
wrong
i know it's anna disanta what do you say
anna diverse
diverse but yeah she's gorgeous wow dude
absolutely gorgeous
stunning amazing actress too very good
scroll down come on yeah give us yeah
you're over here you're gonna message
her this guy that's pretty funny
actually
what do you think that's something i do
in case thank you
i've never had the balls do that mm-hmm
that's the thing i love about christina
right
no matter what i didn't mean
specifically dm but like i've sent
emails on like she's so pretty
she's gorgeous gorgeous
shout out to anna deburs
whoever she is i was going to say going
back to the age of consent thing
they had like a bit where they did like
love that show it was like a
infomercial for the age of consent card
and it just like it was a pocket-sized
thing that said arizona 15 or like every
state state by state so you knew when
you traveled for the age of 2
one of my favorite moments on reno 9-1-1
is uh
they got the
kkk called the cops because someone did
like uh spray-painted over there kkk
sign and they were like people are
messing with our stuff over here and it
was the two black cops that showed up
it was my favorite
uh nick swartz is incredible in that
show oh my god so terry i've watched i
mean they do i have on youtube i don't
want to watch them right now but they
have 15 minute compilations i love that
christian is still just looking at your
phone
i was trying to find i was trying to
find a photo that i could comment on but
she limits all her photos so i can't
even comment on them limits what a power
member
you know you come to a level when you
don't want engagement yeah truly i do
that i was also realizing that
how to do it
oh you don't think i'm smart even though
i just answer all those questions
man [ __ ] you
he's at least as smart as a fourth
grader yeah yeah
what did i get a c on that test i'd say
a b yeah b i missed two questions
okay maybe i do love coming to pages
like this and just seeing like people
that you haven't seen or heard from in
like five years just liking all like
with families and [ __ ] just liking
really creepy photos of them i love the
way yeah instagram just puts people on
blast yeah i love you do you remember
when instagram whose friends that you
don't know in the less nefarious thing
like oh that person followed do you
remember when instagram had the uh like
page where like it shows all your
interactions oh my god that was some
people didn't know that was a thing like
i had a cousin who didn't know it was a
thing until they took it away i was like
you just never checked that page you
just didn't know that you were looking
through what you were doing over and
people could see what you've been so
many people were getting in trouble from
that snapchat had that too where you
could see who the most people are the
most recent people they got rid of that
like the best friends thing like
everyone could see it so you got a
really good thing oh yeah you just
clicked it and it said yeah dude i have
to click on the thing and it would show
you like the people you talk to them
yeah meatball you're on socials is is uh
snapchat like still popping no
no bruh i got rid of that so long ago
because i was like bro this feels like
just so we i don't know it just felt
weird i just use it to talk to my
friends from back home yeah yeah i feel
like snapchat now is kind of like uh for
your close friends only
and it's like they were really early
with group chats yes they were so
they're there i feel like that's like
most of the hold over but i think in
general yeah it's not [ __ ] you try to
pay for content and [ __ ] and like they
pay like big money for you yeah i know
people were having shows on there yeah
snapchat yeah
oh your girl addison right house one on
snapchat now it is that's what she does
what's snapchat
i feel like
at a certain age if you have a snapchat
still it's just a red flag wait how old
is addison ray no she's old enough she's
like 20 21 did you guys ever see the
cringy video of her where she was making
her fans walk watch her film a tic toc
because i asked her for a photo
no
i feel like most things tick tock for
you when you see behind the scenes
footage gorgeous
looks cringy yeah but it's like it's a
part of their job it is what it does
yeah it kind of comes with our
territories he's a tick-tocker
like that yeah they're working maybe
just you know take the picture first and
then don't it is a real weird like
[ __ ] like when you walk around l.a you
just see people making tick-tocks like
content i know those influencers in the
wild pages have you seen oh i love those
but it's it's like yeah people will take
videos of someone doing that like
yeah yeah you see them taking a picture
of food in like a million different
poses they're there for 15 minutes and
[ __ ] yeah it's
i've never
and honestly like
there's
i know people who do it funny and i
respect it but i've never had the
confidence in public to hold my phone up
and very clearly be recording myself
yeah it makes me dude
i i agree with you it's i like i i can't
do it i've had to do it before like for
like a promo and i was like i don't like
this i got to find a different way to do
promos like because i feel like there's
another way to like capture people for
sure i feel like i don't like i feel
like it has to be authentic to me and
like doing that [ __ ] i just don't feel
authentic doing it yeah it's [ __ ]
weird and i feel like
like if my my facebook
the people i'm friends with from back
home i feel like people get sucked into
it and there's these people
everybody's trying to like make content
and talk about oh my god yeah i don't
know like
and i like social media but
there's just aspects man all my friends
they'll be trying to make tick i'm like
if you don't get your ass back to work
[ __ ] what are you doing dude i
have a quick story so you don't have to
i vlog a lot right now right yeah yeah
which is such a pain in the freaking
butt especially because i don't i'm an
introvert i'm uncomfortable in the
public and doing it but i'm like
people and some people enjoy something
i'm going to keep doing this as long as
i can't well thank you yeah so i tried
to do them and then
me and my girl went to a restaurant
recently
and then i was like okay we're gonna i'm
gonna probably do like a we're going to
see what this food tastes like same sort
of food it's an asian kind of food
at this restaurant versus this
restaurant because you know mark wiens
at all i love watching mark winston
there's something about him that reminds
me of jake gyllenhaal's character and
nightcrawler is this is this is this is
this is this what in the world is this
like a food
channel yeah he does all this travel
he's like this asian dude who will kind
of travel the world netflix show too or
something i don't know but he's huge
he's being so old
yeah but so he went to a restaurant and
then we know a restaurant that we
thought was the best for this particular
food yeah so i was like just walk into
the restaurant with my my phone yeah
doing this and i feel uncomfortable
because i'm filming other people as i'm
trying to open the door just to get that
scene
and then
film myself eating
which i hate doing as well
did that finally we went to a market
later on yeah
and then someone runs into the market a
guy he's like
your chin right i'm like yeah he goes
dude really love your vlogs there
i saw the one where you went here and
there here uh he said this the fishing
one right right yeah he said he's in the
vlog no he said this as no as me and me
my girl were just in a restaurant
were you filming at that time no no i
wasn't feeling oh because that would
have been awesome in your vlog someone
came comes up i know they love your vlog
but then he's like i thought he'd be
like oh he's he's like a the cool dude
that watches my stuff so i'm like all
right cool what's your name he's always
his name
i'm chin this is jobo and he's like just
real quick uh when you were walking
through i saw you filming you i think
you caught me and my girl on camera can
you please not show that on your vlog
and i'm like oh of course not this is
more for just me i'm not going to show
anything like that he goes all right
thanks man and then he took off and i'm
like
that's interesting well here's what i'm
thinking though yeah we all know what it
is
i actually am still not sure where this
is going oh i think about it if the dude
came up and said hey man
first of all i thought he's just saying
like yeah
yeah stuff love your work love your
stuff
hey man oh so i get it now yeah yeah he
goes
my girl can you just take that part out
you know and i'm like of course
yeah yeah yeah so what do we all think
he's cheating yeah yeah and his
girlfriend probably watches your content
or maybe she doesn't but he does and
he's like oh crap what if she does were
you at uh were you at a red lobster
oh i love red
is asian restaurant that's the number
one place uh on like surveys that people
take their
their their mistress too yeah they're
the person they're cheating
really i heard this randomly and were
you backtracking there's no way there's
a redness it's red lobster like
the side [ __ ] place to go yeah yeah
let's see the pokemon these biscuits are
[ __ ] good
how would you even look that up
uh popular
probably popular place to take a
mistress if anyone watching this works
at a red lobster and can confirm or oh
yes
let us know i'm so curious now cheaters
choice 10 restaurants where the
unfavorables like to take their secret
dates
oh i mean we could run this down famous
daves applebee's i know yeah
it's not chilly
oh of course yeah del frisco
fleming's really this must be think
about it this must be out there
lobster
number nine oh oh
it's on there
but you know what you know what what's
more what if you're like super [ __ ]
wealthy
and you obviously you don't want to take
her to like an exclusive spot
you're going to take her to chili's
but that's why you take them there
because
your girl wouldn't want to go there
anyways chili's if you especially if you
if you've got loads of money and [ __ ]
yeah but at the same time if you're
famous i don't think you could take them
to chili's because the average person
may know you whereas if you're kind of
like a very wealthy unknown businessman
i can see that
if no one knows who you are yes okay
that's if you're not in entertainment
are you just a wealthy businessman
because if you're a wealthy businessman
in beverly hills and you're used to like
dining at certain places going out
certain places with like your friends
your family the one place no one's gonna
catch you is an applebee's not no okay
like
as a female how would you feel if
someone took me to applebee's see this
is you know the game that you're you
know the game that you're a mistress
yeah you understand you're a mystery
here's the thing
there are i saw this conversation on
tick tock about like there's a
difference between having a
like a mistress or like a side [ __ ]
versus having like someone who's trying
to be a home wrecker whereas like a home
wrecker wants to take the girlfriend's
place a side [ __ ] like knows like where
she stands she knows her lane and just
trying to like play like a good dick
yeah
and the other perks that come with it
but uh
i think if you're a side vision you know
you're elaine like i don't think it
really like those things shouldn't
matter because you know like you're just
there for the good time not a long time
so you kind of do what is necessary like
you're not trying to be seen with this
person whereas if you're the home
wrecker and you want to like take that
the main bitch's spot then you want to
be seen out you then you want him to get
caught up so his wife would leave him
yeah i think that's different
that is
interesting but as like a mistress if
i'm just there to have a good time like
i will be like applebee's is fine i'm
not a bougie [ __ ] i love me
and i also feel like there's usually
other perks along with it yeah they're
paying for something yeah it's
incredible
why isn't denny's on that list
i know that's actually kind of
surprising it's a little too low really
yeah that's like where you take a
prosthetic you need alcohol too you need
alcohol oh daddy's don't have anything
yeah
do they have beer maybe i don't know
great point some of them have alcohol i
don't know what do they have beer maybe
i don't know the ones that have alcohol
i don't remember them having alcohol
what were you saying uh nick uh so i was
just saying like we weave an incredible
web like that the
conversation went earlier when we were
talking about being uncomfortable
and
mo we all are but then like i was saying
people but from back home they'll do it
because like
the social media algorithms know how to
like feed you just like
they get you pumped up i'm convinced tic
toc has a thing everybody i talk to
who's ever tried to make a tick tock
has went viral on tick tock and i think
on your sixth or seventh tick tock they
will make it pop off this was so i saw
there's a podcast that i don't really
listen to but i i watch all their clips
on instagram but it's called podcast but
outside they just put up a folding table
and they'll go to like venice beach or
vegas or outside a bar and then they'll
sit down with anybody who's been uh
who's outside they'll be like we'll pay
a dollar beyond our podcast they've
blown up and they've had jon hamm and
tim dillon on their podcast
but
they
have a bunch of viral tick-tock clips
and they did it like this and this is
now a very common thing to do you know
don't pause
sorry i said this that was sounded like
a cue i feel you
uh but this title thing this is like
just what people do to make simple tick
tocks it's a very common thing that's
essentially your youtube title on tick
tock and like that's what it's called
and this one went viral it was 450 000
views and we've posted 50 tick tock
cents and none of them have gotten like
over
i mean 2 000. you should start another
tick tock account start posting from
there and see if this like is true crazy
it's so hard to grow an account on tick
tock nowadays it's fun it's very
saturated
they
if you swear in it you mentioned any
like anything vulgar anything
that's not pg-13 they will suppress it
and keep it from blowing up
are they also sensitive to accounts that
have previous like strikes like yes mine
like yeah like mine for example like i
can't show you like i imagine that was
on an old account though i made a brand
new account like for you i feel like you
could breathe and they'll probably take
it down because you have a history of
them striking yourself yeah like for
example there was a video of a girl of a
bald girl um who's playing a song that
said like where it goes don't talk to me
and the caption of it was
uh when is kink is hair pulling and she
was like sing along with the song don't
talk to me
and uh i stitched it which or did a duet
with where i'm standing next to that
video
and i just pull out a pic uh a plunger
and like i smile and i laugh they took
it down because apparently it was
harassment and bullying but your boy
fought that and they brought it back up
can we see the video fight the good
fight mine yeah let me play nick's first
and then i'll show you that one all
right
yeah it tells me huh it's more about
dylan he's very funny in this and the
comments are called
tick-tock
25 minutes the next five holes are
jammed up and i said all right we're
gonna leave and go get our money back
whoa they say hey day's completely bust
uh we need the money back
and this girl says uh i'll give you half
how many holes you play 12
right
seems reasonable half yeah yeah and i
said you know what i don't think so
[Laughter]
dylan's kind of okay and
[Music]
yeah your other friend though looks like
uh simon cowell i just remind you of
meatball oh 20 000 views now
super shoe like that
that was it yeah that got taken down
that was it yeah that's crazy that guy
that was going down yep that's very mild
yep
what's happening there
i don't get it
i'm not here
don't get me wrong i just did it because
it was a trending sound at the time i
don't think it was that funny
i think that's the reason why it did
well was because you got a prop though
huh you got a prop yeah
it doesn't mean i thought it was funny
yeah i was just trying to hey
stop playing and show that one
of the girl in the gym i know that one
so little backstory i posted this on my
instagram story
tagged her in it and she viewed it just
never opened it or responded to me i'm a
little terrified i'm a little terrified
now show that one
[Music]
that's really funny
you know what that is right
no you know who the girl is right she's
a fighter i don't know you will know her
you won't know her but we play her again
oh is it valeria yes of course i showed
him valerie lareda i did did you yeah it
was that it was that your was that
during the uh
okay
yeah brian ortega
uh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i've been in
love with this
girl i mean so many people are in love
with it right now yeah oh really i mean
that is funny dude that is funny yeah
especially how do you think i've been in
love with you for four years because
this was way sooner in four years so
someone in your house
valerie loreta this was not four years
ago oh no no i've known her for a while
okay like i've like gone through the
thing of like following her then
unfollowing her because like i follow
her then i see all of your instagram
stories i'm like this girl is terrible
and then i unfollow her yeah i'm not a
fan of her personality yeah why what's
your personality i don't know much about
her short knockout dance yes that's one
thing i don't like i mean this is
awesome let me see i thought it was kind
of hot i'm not talking about that this
is what like popped her off she just let
me see this
personality is being a cuban american
fighter with a fat ass that's her entire
personality
hey have you guys met her no i wish all
right then how do you know her
personality no just through online
personas yeah yeah okay that that's
better
um
oh jesus christ but i'm sure it's
lucrative i always say that i only say
that because i always feel weird judging
people i've never met
i don't even know this person i think
it's also because you work in the
industry you know that like to a certain
degree what you put on social media is a
persona for you to work
like some people are more authentic to
like with their persona to who they
actually are but in one way shape or
another yeah it has to be like kind of a
persona no one in their natural lives in
our industry that i've found is like
always kind of like on instagram like
wanting to post content it's kind of
like it's a part of your job you have to
do it for promo
no matter how good or bad it drives me
crazy how much time are we at we are at
55 34. perfect all right uh so one thing
i want to do here which we did early
with kyle i want to bring oh yeah
is this insane yep i made sure to choose
slow-mo i was gonna say is there a
non-slo-mo and it's really the
smoothness and the speed that
who's she knocked out
she does have a great butt some lunch
lady yeah some lunch lady yeah bellator
women's divisions aren't like so what
people hated on because she danced
no people didn't hate her actually went
viral because it was super cool
slow motion does not do yeah no
definitely i was kind of let down kind
of let down by that it's all good but i
was saying uh as you were saying i wanna
meet uh people to meet the the thick boy
network behind the scenes people uh so i
wanted to bring in uh casey what up
what's
give it up for him
thanks gang
the man that every girl dms about for
[ __ ] boy including me they dm me for him
you didn't even know this no you didn't
know that oh people ask about you all
the time all the ladies who follow thick
boy feel free to pass that along
wow
didn't know i mean chin sent me one like
50 year old chick
i wouldn't say she's 50 but dude i mean
that was my her birthday i don't think
it would hey ain't no wrong with that
shout out to that lady
i was completely uh entrenched what
what are we doing
no we're saying like uh girls are
sending us dms about casey casey
jesus christ valerie
i don't care oh well i'm sorry
it's it's the it's the irish
the irish yeah
but yeah that's what it is uh people who
know chappelle show no casey yeah shop
show too it's not cultural
that's disrespectful yeah it is you're
never allowed back on no
you know he always
[ __ ] him not till he gets it right
hey you don't do nothing
i could volunteer to do social media for
a show right now yeah right
i basically volunteer for it anyway oh
thank you
but yeah hi casey thanks for having me
as much as casey uh is quiet he is kind
of the one who throws the bombs
between us two kind of instigates oh
yeah he'll throw it in there yeah yeah
oh he likes to stir the pot we have a
chapelle's world group text and he uh
we'll drop a little thing every now and
then
kind of slide get him get him going yeah
it's easy with these two
it is i know casey won't even say
anything directed to us he'll just send
something and then chappelle and i just
are that's what it is
we both get riled up easy what i like to
do is like because i edit the episode so
i'll do like a screen grab where
chappelle's making a funny face and then
like make it derogatory towards meatball
and then oh every time every time it has
many devils just
let me pull one up
i don't know what well well he does that
casey what else uh what do you do here
i do uh i'm shooting at it shop show
chapelle's world
haters will say
i shoot food truck diaries and then i
direct the uh fight companions haters
will say
that's dope that's dope yeah and casey
had his own show before too where he's a
writer and or what about actor writer
yeah i did everything wrote directed
acted in it yeah edited it this is the
stuff i'm trying to mine i
i i've known you for a while i didn't
know you know that i didn't know for a
while too and i just i just hit him up
and like what are you doing yeah i
usually don't lead with like hey
he also loves olivia rodrigo like us
[ __ ] yeah
i'm so upset about this because i didn't
know anyone else who liked olivia
rodrigo and so i didn't buy tickets to
her sold out concert because i was like
i'm not going to [ __ ] make stevie go
with me even though he will like i just
i don't want to put him through that i
feel like a loser
and then literally two weeks later i
find out that nick and casey liked her
at the same time damn i was like what is
this we could have had a thick boy
outing we still can we need to we can't
get tickets if anyone can get me tickets
to olivia rodrigo
con
like any
um
no not yet uh she actually came out with
a statement saying that she could have
headlined arenas but she had to start
out smaller just to grow hype around her
but yeah i'm sorry
i just realized did you change the
whiteboard
oh yeah it was 50 off last week now it's
25.
yeah
just an update thanks for writing that
by the way i just wanted to correct it
yeah but yeah i got you wait does that
have to do with something with the show
no he was just writing that being a jerk
well technically he was being supportive
of his friend yeah okay okay thank you
marketing right there we were gonna play
pictionary uh with fans but i think
we're almost running out of time i don't
know we've been going for a while we
could always schedule a pictionary for
another time when we have some guests
locked in we should briefly
bring these people in in a second but
before we did
uh
casey before he worked here
i should have recognized him he uh but
he's in good will hunting
he would totally fit in there
he would are you making a guess or are
you telling us like it's a statement i
thought that's what nick was going to
say i think that's casey affleck
uh but no
he submitted a video question to this
past weekend
which then got turned into a
instagram clip that i edited for theo's
first social and uh i have the link it's
very very very funny what
no and was this before you started
working at the boys yeah this one's a
fan no i think it's uh it says casey
wherever casey is i do not have that
information this was like two three
years ago oh wow really i could send it
to your meatball i don't like how
quickly you got that well like that's
his job you know he's trying to keep the
show on the rails
all right get out
is this how you guys run this operation
i had it oh [ __ ] what'd i do with it you
have it casey
yeah
it was s-booking
also
airspace he also has a blonde wiener dog
he gives me a lot of tips about butters
his name is henry yeah his name is
yeah he has a seven-year-old wiener dog
who is also blonde it's just again
joel's leaner dog wiener dog
i don't uh even you guys the weirdest
way to describe a wiener but definitely
not in years
it's the years don't say a
seven-year-old wiener
dog
yeah just kidding yeah
i think you guys are just emphasizing
thinking about the love
you'll have to get a picture
of your wiener dog to put in the edit i
got you for sure i started over start
over start over
you got this meatball i'm a rollerblader
and uh i've been doing that for
about almost 20 years
damn
bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
what do you do if you love doing
something but everybody else kind of
hates it you never know when you are
ahead of the curve man
i used to scrapbook i grew up
scrapbooking bruh you know what i'm
saying you find me at michael's son post
it up in the back
because a michael's great place to meet
bad [ __ ]
and to do scrapbooking
and i did it for years i got a bunch of
scrapbooks at the house
and bro i couldn't tell anybody i
couldn't tell anybody i was freaking s
bucking
but now
they have dudes on instagram with
3 400 posts
you know what instagram is man
scrapbooking
that's all it is so i was the head of
the curve dude i used to do it the old
way that was very inspirational that was
his version
honestly theo
is coming back the o makes a point too
instagram is just scrapbooking i never
thought with videos that's
a pretty good way to look at it it's
hilarious and also that line where he
goes s boogie wow
that's wild yeah i saved it that's wild
[Laughter]
i'd say let's get him in for an episode
of this but we can barely get him in for
an episode of king and a sing so
fair uh casey do you have highlights of
you rollerblading because he's legit
he's always legit yeah right here if you
go to um go to youtube oh oh wow wow
okay hey youtube okay
type in quesadilla
c-a-s-a-d-i-l-l-a
quesadilla
i love it that's my nickname type in
quesadilla ii i put out four quesadilla
videos oh my gosh
so for all 10 of the women watching if
you want to find casey this is
that's being generous ten
okay seven can they all seven of you
yeah
hang on a minute oh i didn't know i mean
right yeah hitting someone else
so this was like
a year ago quesadilla
whoa
what was the last we saw
no freaking way dude
that's wild
yeah he said why
this was during the pandemic yeah what
the [ __ ] is it that's kind of fire
oh casey get down
[Music]
is that fairfax high school no no
[Music]
dude this is insane casey that kind of
oh yeah that kind of looks like next
when he turned fully then i didn't see
it but uh
where were you
where are you rolling around at
this is all around l.a
that's school yeah he doesn't work
that's downtown downtown
these are all skateboard spots too
chappelle i know that's what i'm saying
like some of these spots look familiar
is it ever like the uh the urchin dude
that was that was fire
like skiers were snowboarders
tsunami like skaters would come and kick
your ass
um there's definite it's i mean
now it's pretty cool and like i'm good
yeah so
skateboarders don't give me [ __ ] like
especially if you go to a skate park and
you're like
better at the skate park than some
skateboard like they're not going to
give you [ __ ] but that doesn't mean that
i haven't like got into [ __ ] with
skateboarders how good are you because
this looks like uh this looks pro is fun
yeah this looks super pro are you
supposed to
oh no i know something watch this one
dude
yeah that's wild
yeah i'm [ __ ] good yeah but you need
to watch brink if you're a role player
no he doesn't need to watch before he's
older than brink brink has nothing to do
with rolling away that's like bring it
on for cheerleading
thank you thank you thank you you see
what i'm saying
drink has nothing to do with nothing no
not for what he does i know what you
mean you know what i mean but bring it
on is a good movie and so is brink so
ever
enjoy good cinema but it doesn't but it
doesn't should we have movie night
dude
you got the audio
it's a it's about rollerblading bring it
on it's about cheerleading but that's
not what they are
that's not that's not what it is what do
you what i'm saying that's not rolling
but what rollerblading is that's not
what cheerleading is you see what i'm
saying i mean it it is robulating for
that age group of the movie like that's
what it is no
i'm not talking about cheerleading i
agree with you on the bringing on front
i just want to know if casey is team x
blades or team puppets
i know i was like soap and pubs
what is that
that's the the the team names on brink
oh god casey are you sponsored i was
yeah
when was this how long retired
how long was that that was last year you
were why did you retire
um
i don't know man i i got i i'm kind of
like a one thing at a time guy and i got
into golf and i'm like you know what i'm
37 now i can't be throwing myself
downstairs anymore i still skate like we
do every sunday we go to a different
skate park in l.a me and like my crew of
like 20 of us but oh damn dude that's so
pro dude i'm surprised you're not like
pro pro i was you were pro pro i was pro
pro
that's me
i didn't have like a pro skate or a pro
wheel or anything so technically that's
what you need to be like considered pro
but i had like uh
offers
that's dope dude dude
and i know this is like just uh what are
you shooting now for golf
cake i'm like a turn handicap
and you've been playing how long
i played as a kid and i actually played
on my high school team and then i quit
that
uh you know my favorite thing about this
video
them ducks never move
they're always there on that they're not
really they're lucky i ain't
i playing look it they don't move my
friend uh killed a squirrel playing golf
wait this is his blog ran out as he hit
a shot that's henry oh that's adorable
that's a solid pick of henry i hit my
buddy in the calf
in high school from like 90 yards away
at like a 30 degree angle just walk in
drilled him he turned and hit him right
in the cafe
oh well so you're trash oh yeah yeah oh
yeah i i mean
golf
you need all the things that i don't
have
[Music]
this concentration ability to like block
[ __ ] out uh
damn you're preaching to the choir i
feel the exact same way
i don't know don't like casey i can hear
everything people are like don't lift
your head up
exactly
i top the ball i top the ball and i get
angry then after that uh yeah stoicism
yeah the books must must help you though
you got to be very good here now yeah
i'm even getting fired up just thinking
i don't like though
[Laughter]
you got to be very stoic
that's why i usually slam like nine
michelob ultras while you're out there
no
but then i end up just like
chilling in the passenger seat of the
golf cart as other people still a good
time
how do you feel about uh golf cart girls
amazing see i keep getting videos of
them on my tick tock feed and i don't
know why because i hate golf but i love
what they're doing that seems like so
much fun they're basically like
good-looking young girls who are in
charge of like the beverages and the
snacks on a golf cart and they like will
sell to
the men who are playing usually because
it's usually men they're buying they
just get it yeah yeah i love [ __ ] like
that anything where a girl gets to look
cute and sell things and get great tips
from men
love it love it
i don't like to partake i like to watch
from afar do they dress really like
extra no it's just like a regular kind
of uniform yeah yeah it's very
there's nothing like salacious it's not
like it's just like that it's not like
going on pretty good coffee shop at a
golf course yeah all the time the course
i frequent the car girls are
[Laughter]
what an incredible account of yourself
uh casey you want to stick around while
we zoom in this fan yeah
uh
great
you got this meatball
oh we got someone
yeah someone someone's on oh yeah just
flip switch that one
it's all good we can vamp huh pull it in
yes
there you go meatball there we go
press record don't let anyone yell at
you for your production yeah you're
doing has learned you're learning on the
job and this isn't great there's some
guy who's commented this twice on uh
look refreshing different videos you do
look refreshing
nick the way you read your passive
aggressiveness with meatball is
portrayed through the screen is
confusing like he's in the same spot you
were don't treat him like an employee
treat him like he's a part of the team
becomes the abuser no no no this is just
some guy that said this on two different
on two different uh you see what i said
back to him yeah you said it was all he
was like it's all love yeah i [ __ ]
had nick's back yeah yeah and what did
that guy say what did he say to that
nothing because he knew i'd [ __ ] him up
if he didn't nick again he's training
he's trying to protect you by the way
training days i appreciate you trying to
respect uh reach out to me and protect
me but ashtray and fresco yeah did you
watch a lot of x games yeah casey yeah
uh those japanese brothers the yasa
tocos the yasutokos were so dope yeah i
like i i always thought it was weird how
much i hate rollerblading yeah i mean
rollerblading got
cut from the x games oh jesus hi oh
really yeah there was what's up dog is
it bad can you hear us can you hear us
no can you hear us
i can't hear you might be
but we are live to tape right now nick
is this one of your homies no this is uh
someone uh
johnson uh johnson for a second i'm not
gonna lie he's got a little bit of that
look chappelle chappelle thought i was
just bringing in a buddy
hey you got friends
no this is a a a thick boy
boy are you thick
and you play guitar
i got a couple it's my wife's desk
my stuff's behind my monitor but no four
thousand dollar collection we're like
hey let's go baby five thousand five
thousand five thousand oh five thousand
five thousand because of chin
[Laughter]
where are you at or like uh indianapolis
indianapolis indiana hell yeah shouts
out let's go
where there's zero comedy
oh really
uh
don't ever come here
[Laughter]
i love how honest you are i just went to
nashville two weeks ago
oh yeah
uh what you're born and raised you're
born born and raised in indianapolis
native
damn
uh so
i was gonna ask you
if you're smarter than a fifth grader
yeah oh yeah baby
because we found out we aren't yes
let's see what you got
all right i grew up watching that show
that's dope that's funny did we ask him
um
i'll keep my hands out too so you don't
seem to google and stuff okay i'm solid
i respect this guy but also he already
told us he has a he has a wife who's
definitely i feel like they're partners
and she might be helping out in the back
no no
she's got the other airpods
she's got the other airpods yeah where's
the other airport huh
you didn't even know what we were doing
how did you do that
sour patch airpods okay we trust that
you gotta come prepared man
all right so
in elementary school what was your worst
subject
elementary school first to fifth grade
uh science all right science fair was
the least thing of my uh
whatever
interest all right let's see what we got
all right so we're gonna start you off
easy then we're going to start you off
with a
first grade science question all right
[ __ ] you me
let's go easy
snow
rain and sleet are all examples of what
a liquid
i don't know i think that counts i think
that counts but i bet the answer is
precipitation that's it that counts like
rain man what the hell
good pun
wait
all right precipitation now we're gonna
do a different uh subject we will do
english language arts we're going to up
it to second grade
all right
what type of literature features magical
creatures such as giants gnomes and
goblins
it's a type of genre
genre genre
oh wait does he get to phone in a friend
like we did or no
say that again
science
i do sorry we just couldn't hear you in
uh
it's not science fiction but it's close
[Music]
very close
practically the same thing yeah right
yeah yeah just just just uh non-fiction
i don't know all right now you're
getting further away yeah now you're
further away yeah again go to the judges
nick says both are acceptable answers
your answer is fantasy nope oh damn it
mythology nothing
nope
jesus christ fairy tales people fairies
oh it's fairy tales oh sorry it's so bad
that wasn't fairy tales that's a okay i
guess dude no but see this is still
working it's a shame
i'm not blaming meatball that's a [ __ ]
question yeah that wasn't any text they
said they shouldn't have put that on
there i mean that's just common sense
fairy tales come on but it's also
fiction too
fantasy two things fantasy sci-fi stuff
all right how's your history on
knowledge
hip
the statue of liberty was a gift from
where
which country
right country france yay
why is it green yeah why is it why is it
green yeah why is it
topper and it turned green over the
years dude he's right he said what made
it he said brian
yeah i i said oh my god
i'm gonna get torn apart
oh you said bro
[Music]
in the youtube section of people
corrected me and then an hour and a half
later they'd be like we told you
who paid for christopher columbus's
explorations
oh
wait you're you were uh you're too deep
in the mic what you say
who who paid for christopher columbus's
explorations
uh
whatever village he robbed and took
that's a very fair uh answer does anyone
does anyone know is it the case in court
i'm going to guess but no is it king
arthur the king of england at the time i
was just going to say spain
oh oh george iii the third it was just
in general the spanish royals oh spanish
royals
nick
nick with the flex
he's actually kind of smart
he's actually kind of sorry wait what
was his answer what was his answer and
the people he stole oh the other people
[Laughter]
well i really really like this guy yeah
uh let's do two more questions uh two
more questions okay and then maybe we'll
have to
bring
oh no we want to do it with someone's
uh we want someone to zoom in you have a
child do you do you want me to volunteer
to do all you guys with social media for
you is that why you're ringing me in
right now
i mean
sucks
no this is no no
[Laughter]
oh yeah oh yeah
you seem a bit like a busy guy
i'm gonna do i'm gonna give you the same
question we asked them earlier
uh another one
what are the three branches of the
united states government
oh man well my wife would love this
question i don't know
[Laughter]
he's killing the
game you give me one maybe i'll be able
to give you two but i don't know okay i
don't know if i'll give him one nick go
ahead nick cause nick got it okay uh
i'll give you the one i didn't know
earlier exac i couldn't place the name
executive
i love that you're honest
hey man yeah no i didn't know it either
so i had to give it to someone else to
make me feel better about myself
sad thing is i went to a private school
and a public school so and the public
schools are also funded by the
government
uh legislative and uh judicial judicial
all right and then the last the courts
congress and senate and the president
all right what was that all right nick
yeah all right
um italy japan and germans alliance was
called what oh world war ii i know this
one you're not on you're not in the hot
seat because i know history oh he looks
like he knows i know can i hey if he
doesn't get it let me answer it
nate no no he you need a license you
ready to pick one cat's memory come on
man
except for chappelle
axis
what's the question again say that
question italy japan ger and germany so
alliance is called what they're all
allies of what
that are called i'm way off i have no
clue i don't either
the axis of evil
dude of evil what
how did you get to look why would they
be called accidents i love propaganda
of evil yeah
what i was trying to feed it to you
chappelle oh as your loyal
that's why i was saying it kind of
counts because you got half of it right
yeah i feel like nick is way smarter
than he lets on i know no i think nick
is super smart i think we just don't
give them credit for it because we don't
yeah when you look always listen to
those little tidbits wild cards
he's like a silent assassin or did he
just find his wheelhouse in fifth grade
and young
that's fair that was his favorite
drawing i'm just asking the question
do people think i'm [ __ ]
[Music]
i don't think completely
i'm gonna believe that
can we use that as a cold open please
you
was it your idea to do smarter than a
fifth grader uh
no it was a comment youtube okay mm-hmm
he's gonna say what was it okay so based
off of what you got right and what you
got wrong
is he smarter than a fifth grader
because none of us were except for nick
do you think is this a pass or a fake
one right yeah yeah he got here he got
one right now i got like three parts of
that one right so you basically got like
two and a half right right you just
still failed
yeah and have too solid but i'll take
the two and a half over appreciate that
so he's like a d student fifth grader
yes asmr barely fine he's as smart as
his figure smarter but asmr what was
your most solid look what was your most
solid subject
in growing up what was your favorite
subject
[ __ ] yeah why are you doing nothing
didn't have one unfortunately you don't
want a better one if you don't mind me
asking me what what subject did you
perform the best then
okay forget it
you know what mine was give me some
obstacle courses yeah
i said jim earlier oh mine was lunch
okay like jim was your favorite solid
okay then do 25 pull-ups for us on zoom
right now then i don't know meatball
yeah you have a rope in your living room
yeah you think you think everyone's on
steroids
yes with the people i work with yeah
yeah do you have a little parachute
thing that you would get under as a kid
and they would oh you run in there
do you have that
you don't have that it's so underrated
what about a four wheeled super fast car
yup those things the [ __ ]
fields
uh
how do you put food on the table do we
have do we what do you do what do you do
for a living yeah
uh i started my own
construction business six years ago wow
word word uh so that's how i know about
statue of liberty and what is going on
with the paint and all that it's not
pain it's actually coffee yeah
i called the bronze earlier like an
idiot do you want to shout it out or
would you like to keep that private
uh no it's a pro finish i'd redo
kitchens and stuff man
uh there could be obviously
bro [ __ ] yeah all right well if anyone
needs their uh kitchens redone in
indianapolis hit up brian not pro
kitchen
he'll get him done yeah pro finish
profanity7.com but uh
that's all i got he may not
appreciate you guys thanks for joining
us man you may not be smarter than a
fifth grader but you can construct a
mean kitchen yeah better than a fifth
grader better than fifty very true
so you got something for your dog
all right brian all right brian thanks
for tuning in brother thank you
all right
later
that was fun
yeah
i love people's honesty when they're
like i don't know i don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
whoa
that's it yeah that's it man thanks for
tuning in the cat's after dark again we
do have that audio
as well would you would you have to
follow follow cats after dark on spotify
and apple podcast and dick boy on
youtube yeah they want youtube um what
else oh i'll be in utah
april 8th and april 9th at salt lake
city at wiseguys
and then may 6th to may 7th i'll be in
san diego at a new comedy club called
mike dropped uh and then
may 12th right and then may 12th i'll be
doing a one-nighter in the hometown uh
phoenix stand up live
uh tickets at prolacey.com and then cats
uh only fans is 20 off 25 off yeah i'm
keeping the sale up uh it's 25 now if
anybody wants pictures of my feet or me
yeah um and make sure to get it fast
because because it's going their
discounts going smaller and smaller
every week last week it was 50. yeah
there's an announcement 25 so make sure
you get it while the discount lasts yes
urgency it's in marketing another below
deck podcast crazy season
check out chen's vlogs at chen
youtube.com
casey
um if you're a 50 year old lady hey no
don't test the dm
and check out quesadilla 2 on youtube
mm-hmm all seven of them golfing yeah
all seven of you
yeah wait they was wait they've dm do
you
i feel like just in general there's
always comments about if casey's in a
video even for a second there's always
someone saying like oh who's that
emoji
[Laughter]
he could just sit there it's just
[ __ ] pretty
cutest in the yearbook so i'm not going
to dance
he also loves bette midler bette midler
if you're watching this yeah
he loves you
yeah yeah that was a goof you guys no no
it's not it's fine you like what you
like hit me up a bit
love and then uh christian uh see people
[Music]
thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]
you